this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] oh [__] it's Monday March
the 14th the joint is brought to you by
bluetooth Blow Me I'm Irish you won't
need the Luck of the Irish on Saint
Patty's Day when you got Bluetooth and
your [__] pocket let me tell
you some Bluetooth is tremendous you can
take it anywhere
anytime
within minutes you'll be ready to
[__] rock and roll nobody could stop
you listen I don't care if you don't
have Ed but if you need a little extra
confidence Bluetooth is here for you
when you're ready to sling dick you can
take it anytime day or night the process
is simple sign up at bluetooth.com and
talk to one of the licensed medical
providers once you're approved you'll
receive your prescription within days
the best part of it it's all online guys
no doctor's office no Pharmacy no
[__] brow beating and it ships to
your door and a discreet package nobody
knows dicks not even the mailman
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
and they're way cheaper than a pharmacy
so if you can perform
a little extra better with some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help I love this stuff
guys and they got a special deal for the
joint family you ready try Bluetooth
free
when you use my promo code Joey j-o-e-y
at checkout just pay five bucks for
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
Joey j-o-e-y to receive your first month
free that's right free I'm showing up
Monday and giving you something for free
who's better Uncle Joey nobody so do me
a favor visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and I want to thank Bluetooth for
sponsoring The Joint the joint is also
brought to you by oh [__] I told you
[__]
DraftKings join the action on the court
during the biggest college basketball
tournament of the year the teams got
announced yesterday and we're turning
this party on on Thursday turn your
team's Victory into your win new
customers you ready for the deal I got
for you five dollars on any team to win
and you get 200 and free bets 200 rounds
That You're Gonna Keep betting over for
the final until the final four comes in
if they win you win if Sportsbook isn't
available in your state yet let me tell
you something for college hoops there's
nothing like DraftKings pools everybody
can play free pools all March long for a
shot at a share at 250 000 prizes did
you hear me everyone can play for free
with the free pools at DraftKings with
the ultimate goal being 250
000 000 prizes but it starts with you on
a Monday download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app today use promo code Joey
j-o-e-y but five dollars many college
hoops team to win and get 200 in free
bets if they do it's that simple if they
you win you win I win everybody [__]
wins with promo code Joey j-o-e-y this
week at DraftKings Sportsbook 21 over
restrictions do apply let's get this
[__] party started on a Monday
morning
welcome to Uncle Joey's Joy
[Music]
foreign
of March a beautiful [__] day
to be alive welcome to Uncle Joey's
joint for another fun film Monday
morning take Tate to get your week off
and [__] running I had a great
weekend Lee didn't come down because it
was going to snow Saturday
and he didn't want to get stuck in the
snow hopefully that's our last [__]
snow of the year that's it man and
listen it don't bother me at all it
didn't bother me whatsoever I gotta be
honest with you guys when they talk
about global warming and all this [__]
I'm not a scientist I don't know much
about it but I will tell you one thing
februaries in this state used to be
[__] brutal when I was growing up
januaries in this state used to be
januaries I will never ever forget
January's in New York City and in New
Jersey
February's used to be [__] brutal I
still remember my eighth grade year
we didn't get out of school until June
30th because it just snowed they had a
two or three weeks off the Blizzard of
78 83 when Rego beat up the [__] dude
on the bicycle remember no [__] skin
on Bergenline Avenue you know those
snowstorms are [__] legendary we
don't get these here
so this is what tells me that the tide
is Shifting here I'm like again I'm no
scientist I'm no [__] Greta whatever
that little girl's name is yeah Greta
Van Fleet all I'm doing here is what I
see you know when I grew up in this
[__] State listen yeah I was a
criminal I did a lot of [__] up [__] I
was ashamed
but don't believe the hype you want me
to tell you what kicked me out of this
state humility I can't stand the [__]
humidity I mean I can't stand it my
[__] heart is [__] moments as a
child was trying to get my dicks up 14
13 Going to parties and [__] I would
wash thoroughly do you understand me
because I never wanted somebody to say
you know what I fooled around with Joey
and his [__] smelled like a [__]
goat or anything like that so I used to
bathe pretty [__] good
and I would go up down to these parties
and not walk up that two mile walk by
the time I got up there my hair would be
[__] frizzy as [__] it was like a Jew
for all what do you think you guys why
do you think I put monkey spit in my
[__] hair because I like to no
because my hair [__] blow up every
goddamn day it goes from being an afro
to being a [__] I look like Zach de
la Rocha from [__] Rage Against the
Machine it's a [__] nightmare so by
the time I get there my balls would be
sweaty my [__] would be sweaty I
would be sweating and my hair would be
all [__] over the place and I hated
it you normally [__] nights I came
home with my jeans drenched from sweat
I could say 10 times one time I remember
after the Palladium show with AC DC I
[__] came home the top rim of my
jeans were drenched you could squeeze it
you could squeeze it and I wasn't
jumping up and down I wasn't running up
and down [__] Kennedy Boulevard
you know it's just that's how [__]
hot it is guys but that's not that
hasn't been the [__] case at all so
whatever I don't give a [__] as long as
it don't snow no more this year it was
what we got three snowstorms four little
[__] snow storms one was a big one
but not really we were [__] back
through it the next hour you know so but
anyway what I want to talk to you guys
about was uh Thursday night I went up to
North I went up to Cliffside Park I went
up to Rudy's I uh
seen my nephew Nikki I saw Uncle George
I saw Lisa but I had to meet a friend of
mine my agent and uh Rudy's you know so
at first I'm like [__] I don't feel like
taking the ride then I was like [__]
yeah let's go up there you know I'm not
doing nothing down here I shot up there
I got up there on time I brought a
couple gifts for the people I brought a
nice looking little jaw ABX Edibles my
man Tommy he sees those things he Scoops
up a bowl of clam chowder to Rhode
Island oh if you go to Rudy's get the
Rhode Island clam Chow to [__] New
England [__] Manhattan go Rhode Island
that [__] will set you free I
had a hard on the whole [__] drive
down from the crab meat and God knows
what else was in that [__] Rhode
Island uh
but you know whenever I go
like I'm not
maybe not the last three times I went up
you know when I go to North Bergen I
just want to get the [__] out of him
like when I go to Cliffside Park I eat I
relax I laugh a little bit
and what I usually do is sometimes I'll
drive through North Bergen but sometimes
I'll just take tunneling and [__]
shoot on the three whatever West East
whatever the [__] it is and I'm back
home in an hour 55 minutes you know but
there's just some like I got a next
couple weeks I gotta go up there
and put some flowers on my mother's
grave I gotta drive around the
neighborhood see how it's looking maybe
some old Spirits made a comeback you
know the whole [__] deal
but Thursday night I went up there and
I'm like you know it's uh
I got there at five we were done by
seven
it was a little dark out it hadn't
gotten too dark yet so I said let me
just take a [__] ride you know let me
just see what's cracking North Bergen
I went down Bergenline Avenue I passed
the [__] uh Burger King where I put
my dick on the [__] counter I went
down
I went down to uh
76 whatever and I hooked the [__] not
even not even what am I saying Joey I
hooked her right by uh I don't know 85th
Street and I went down to Kelly
Boulevard it came out to my regs
with the old meringues it's not my race
no more brakes was a bar up there
so I wanted to go down 91st Street Hill
and see Kurt's house Kurt delorenzo's
out
but you can't make a [__]
left turns into [__] 88th Street
so I went down 90th whatever and I came
up uh Smith Avenue I don't even know
what the streets are anymore you know I
just driving from what I remember I know
that
you can't make a right and go down 88th
Street Park anymore you know so you have
to come up from it from the bottom or
whatever Grand Avenue
so I hit Grand Avenue
and I [__] uh
I hit Grand Avenue and I popped up Kurtz
you know for some reason I was just
saying Kurt like I just wanted to see I
drove by Ronnie's house
[__] the streets of [__] like
midgets I don't know how the [__] we
grew up there I really don't I really
[__] don't know how I grew up there
because the streets are [__] nothing
like nothing I was petrified I was gonna
hit a car with my rear view mirror I
mean it's [__] scary as [__] so I
make the [__] right from Grand Avenue
go back up the Kennedy Boulevard I
stopped the car and I didn't stop it
like I was doing two miles an hour on
the turn and I looked at Kurt's house
it's changed and [__]
I remembered [__] like 83 saying
cause halfway up the corner of the
[__]
Kennedy Boulevard to buy coke from Kurt
they'd be in a [__] line like an ATM
machine just craziness
and as I'm heading up to [__] Kennedy
Boulevard
I go holy [__] and I looked over and
there it was now
I know it's not the same one like I've
been there and I smelt it it's
definitely not the same one but I saw my
rocket ship I saw my old hotel the
outdoor when I was [__] homeless and
I got to tell you something I looked at
it guys like I looked
and that's when it dawned on me
and I had to pull over for a second I
didn't get out of my car there was
nobody at the [__] Park I mean it's
not when we were kids we were always at
that [__] Park like at seven getting
our night started so it had to be about
seven o'clock there was nobody at the
park
but I just parked the car for a minute
and I looked at that because I'd
forgotten all about
the [__] rocket ship I really did I
forgot everything to do with being
homeless we covered it in the books but
God knows that was maybe last year
so I just pulled the car over and I just
looked at that thing and I I could not
believe
that I slept there for about three
[__] weeks in December of 84. I I
just couldn't believe it
I just could not [__] believe it let
me tell you the weirdest thing that
that whole reason why I was homeless and
living in that rocket ship
was because the family on that corner
had offered me if I wanted to stay with
them they were like listen we're sick
and tired of hearing these stories about
you
why don't you stay with us in the
basement we got the kids here and the
families
and uh you get on your feet get a job
whatever but you know what I I don't
even I don't even remember when I moved
in with them I think I was there a
[__] month maybe maybe a month I was
there and a couple nights I would go
home and that's how I knew about the
rocket ship because I couldn't get in I
didn't have keys so I had to go home
like by two or three or there were two
kids in the house Tommy and I would tell
Tommy leave the back door open sometimes
he'd forget and I'd have to go to the
rocket ship and
just sit there until they opened up the
house when the kids went to school at
eight and I'd sneak in and
you know who knows what my life was
about that you know I have no [__]
idea I just know that
I sat in that car for like 15 minutes
and I did not feel good I just did not
feel good about myself you know and I
was doing great that night I was having
a good time but just that whole
situation [__] killed me and to make
it worse
Friday
I was on Facebook and I saw a picture of
the girl that lived in that house that
was my dear friend I mean she was my
dear friend bro
and you know I moved in with them they
were very nice of them to let me move in
I was going through a
I was just a [__] junkie I wasn't
going through anything I was just a
[__] junkie it was 19 [__] 84.
that [__] was everywhere you know that
[__] was everywhere guys it if you're
young you would never understand how
much cocaine there was around this
[__] neighborhoods
by 84.85
everybody was doing coke your mother
your father your aunts your uncles your
cousins
everybody was sniffling
everybody thought they were Tony Montana
it's such a [__] hard picket to
describe you know like when I think
about living in L.A when the weed store
is really were at that Peak like right
now weed stores retail you know people
are realizing that the wheat prices went
up
and then you gotta add the taxes to it
so people like [__] it I'm back to where
I was I might as well go to my dealer
I might as well go to my [__] deal
and get a go on the black market it's a
black market who the [__] knows what
that even is
so uh it all started with that [__]
man I was I was not
in a good space you know that's why I'm
happy when Justin May paluso came on
here
and we spoke about uh you know grief you
know let me tell you something man that
[__] is worse than a [__] addiction
because you don't even know when it's
crawling up on you
you know you don't even feel it you just
know you're going through some changes
and then when you hit rock bottom
you when you you know do a
self-inventory or what the [__] is going
on with you you're like
I miss my mother I miss my best friend
I'm you know whatever the [__] it was
and I was not stable those months at all
like
I wasn't suicidal
but I also didn't want to keep doing
what I was doing I didn't deserve to
live what I was doing it was grief it
was uh
you know when you feel bad for yourself
self-loathing whatever it was that it
was and then the addict the cocaine
didn't you know when you're [__]
unstable
and then you add cocaine to the [__]
mix
that's the beginning of the end that's
the beginning of the end when you're in
that point of being unstable I shouldn't
even have been getting high like I
shouldn't even looking back now you know
looking back but I will tell you
something
in other parts of my life when I felt a
little unstable like last year when I
was going through what I was going
through
that's why I don't like smoking pot if
you're going to rebuild
you got to rebuild from strength not
from [__] uh
drugs or whatever like that that was
that's my assessment of it you know
so it was just oh my God
and I didn't want to get out like I was
thinking of getting out and walking over
to the rocket ship no that's too strong
I did that I did that I went up there
with my daughter and my wife five four
years ago six years ago and I went and
touched the rocket ship first off I'm
not gonna lie to you it's not the same
rocket ship that rocket ship was 19
[__] 83 and it had probably been that
20 years there was some rusty spots
there was some spots where you get
caught on the [__] boats like your
clothes this was not a kosher rocket
ship you know what I'm saying I wouldn't
let my daughter play in that old rocket
ship this was one from like the 60s when
they opened up that Park the one they
had there now was just a new one listen
it's not even used
that thing has probably been there for
10 years and maybe you know it's gotten
five days to use it's not like when we
were kids and we were in that park or
you know that whole neighborhood had a
bunch of [__] kids and they hung out
at that Park they started by writing the
[__] things in there then you go play
baseball then there's a huge basketball
court then
that's the [__] Parker we ended up
mugging the Chinese dude we met him
delivered down to the park and we mugged
the Chinese guy and we took his car and
delivered Chinese food
we went to the park later on the cops
were there with the Chinese delivery
driver oh my God
damn we made like two or three
deliveries you know picked up like 60
bucks we thought we were gangsters we're
driving around and the [__] got his
stolen car hey man that's what it was
all about back then I'll tell you we
just made like three deliveries nobody
went to jail
nobody got beat up I think we duct taped
the delivery driver we took them out we
took them down or something like that
right in the Eighth Street Park [__]
hysterical guys this is this is
childhood [__] that will never happen
again because they'll throw you under
the jail for doing something like that
[__] just taking a delivery driver
out and delivering Chinese food and even
the people looking at you weird like why
are you delivering where's the [__]
you know I'm saying what does the
Chinese do with the railroad
so it's just [__] uh that was such a
[__] horrible time
such you know and I I started going in
that direction I and I took it right
back to like L.A like I was starting to
feel like it was taking me down and I
started thinking about being on stage
and all that [__] how you know I did so
many things from that point in my life
but I'm gonna be as honest I can with
you
I still know it but I was [__]
homeless I still know it like you don't
even wanna most people wouldn't say that
it's like being a prostitute you know
what I'm saying like if you're a
prostitute and you meet a bunch of new
people and then you're like what have
you been doing the last eight years uh
you know
I've been a prostitute now I I just been
busy that's what I felt like I just been
busy it's the truth you're busy I'm busy
it's uh
I'm embarrassed about it and I still
remember it deep
like it cuts deep in there with the
prison [__]
see I've never listened the only way I
can alleviate the pain from all that
[__] I'd done to myself was to make fun
of it that's the only way that listen
you're a true comedian
when you can make yourself laugh in a
tough situation
that's when you should really consider
maybe I'll do comedy because if you
could do that for yourself
could you imagine what you could do for
other people I knew that that's one of
the biggest traits of being a comedian
is cracking yourself the [__] up
I love cracking myself up because the
first thing I do is take whatever the
[__] I just said to Mike or Lee or
whoever and I put a notebook and we work
from there you work it from [__] name
you take it you're right out the [__]
way but
that's the true test when you're like
[__] feeling down you know and you're
like I can make myself laugh and that
was also around the time like that was a
rough [__] two months guys and there
was no [__] better help for me that
like you understand me like I wish
[__] better help was there with me at
that time while we're here let's read
better help for you there was no better
help in fact when I talked to her next
Monday I'm gonna bring up this thing
that I'm talking to you guys about today
because that dog there was no better
help
there was no [__] nobody to help me
out there was nobody to [__] pain
because remember Maybe
it was in that genre
from uh mid-september to December 31 of
84. one of those weekends was when I got
high like from Thursday all the way to
Sunday
and instead of going to the rocket ship
I broke into Mike Ronnie's house who
just called me a couple of minutes ago
my brother
and uh he used to have like a in the
room where we lifted weights in the
basement
it was like those glasses that you put
in individually but then you have to
spin it around and the glass goes like
this well I figured out how to take the
glasses out and climb in and I put the
glasses back and [__] then one night one
of the glasses broke and I'm like pop oh
but one night I went over there and they
had this dog Duke I love [__] Duke
but when Duke didn't go out he would
[__] downstairs in the back room so when
you walk down to the basement
they'd have uh
they'd have
the washing machine and uh
they had the washing machine to dry and
then you walked straight there was a
bathroom there was mine and Mike's room
on the left hand side and then there was
another room over there
that was the weightlifting room we put
chairs and [__] in there we would dip
and we had an incline bench in there
that we made from [__] scratch like
Puerto Ricans and then in the back back
room was where the boiler was and where
the dude checked the [__] meter but
back there whenever you know Duke
couldn't go out he would just go back
there and drop a piece of [__] that was
like maybe four pieces of [__] Duke
didn't [__] in the [__] basement all
the time but [__] I used to
crawl into the gym and then go into the
back room so nobody would see me they
wouldn't even know I was back there
there were two old mattresses back then
I would just put them on the floor
and one night oh my God one night I was
high for [__] three days
yeah it was like a Sunday night and I
had been going since Thursday night guys
think about it
I don't know what happened on Sunday I
do not remember
but at one point of the day I ended up
at Mike runny's house after a three-day
[__] run
okay
I'm [__] I crawled through a window
boom I usually I do my usual I throw
down the [__] mattress real quietly
and I'm [__] up I don't know what I
got in me I got blow I got booze I got I
don't know what type of method of method
I do pills you know I'm [__] up guys I
had already puked
it was horrible it was the end of a
three-day binge you know you're all out
of [__] dopamine you know what I'm
saying so you're [__] just depressed
and I'll never forget I drew the
mattress down
I just took the mattress in the wall and
laid it down and as I started taking my
jacket I didn't notice where I had put
the mattress I took the jacket off and I
followed up to use like a pillow I threw
it down and when I laid on the pillow I
opened my eyes
and I was [__] just you know like
when you lay down and you're like
I finally you know I could breathe but
when you do Coke if anybody ever done
Coke at the end of a Coke binge is when
you sit on your bed
your dick won't get hard
you know you try jerking off that's not
working
and then you [__] finally realize the
position you put yourself in I've been
smoking Coke for three days I can't get
a hard on I'm broke I owe the guy eight
thousand dollars
and then that last minute you go to take
a breath like
what am I gonna do with my life you know
I'll never forget that I was like just
not feeling good I wasn't I was on that
mattress for about maybe 10 minutes
just my mind was racing with all the
[__]
my mind was racing with all the [__]
that I had got you know like when is
this gonna end type
[__] going on with your brain
and I said to myself I never forget to
say God
you know man I'm gonna [__] sleep for
a few hours and I'm gonna end this
I'm gonna end this I had a cousin who
jumped off the George Washington Bridge
I go [__] it I'm gonna walk through the
George Washington Bridge
and jump off the [__] Bridge let me
take a nap for a few hours
let me get my paperwork together let me
write a will you know I'm going to leave
my jacket to somebody that's all I had
at the time
[Music]
something like all right let me return
you know you don't say let me turn over
like I went like this like to turn it
over and I smelt something funny
and maybe like this was my [__] face
over here and right here where this
water was Duke had taken a little [__]
that was frozen or something like I had
disintegrated and it came back to life
like I I don't you know you ever see
Michael Jackson Remember the Time the
video they have like the sand and then
it comes back like that's what it was it
was like a little mountain of sand but
as depressed as I was at that moment
when I opened up my eyes and I saw a
little piece of [__]
I'm like I'm killing myself today at
lunchtime this is that that piece of
[__] right there that's the sign I gotta
ice myself I can't keep doing this to
myself you think I'm [__] kidding you
Mike I'm out of my mind
and I broke down I cried a little bit
I'm like how bad am I that after
everything I'm going through I had to
actually lay down
next to a piece of [__] I'm waiting to
think about that when you you know how
bad is my [__] life you want to tell
me guys
and I'm just laying there for two
minutes looking at that piece of [__]
going you know what I have to jump off
this [__] Bridge that's my sign
that's my future [__] I'm gonna jump off
the [__] bridge I I woke up at lunch
time I walk like halfway and I said [__]
it let me get a Palmer sandwich and
let's find the 50 Bill to get this party
started today you know what I'm saying
whatever the [__] you were thinking it's
so quick like that night I had a plan
I'm gonna [__] kill myself I'm gonna
jump I'm gonna eat a hot dog you know
all this [__] and I get up and it's a
different [__] plan it's the same
thing like when you make a plan not to
get high anymore I'm gonna stop getting
high I'm gonna stop [__] my aunt you
know I gotta I gotta move out you know
like you're just in a [__] horrible
situation in your life
dog I've been in those situations a
[__] lot in my life when I wrote that
book I thought about all the times I
started over
holy [__] nobody that's why I know how
to start over I give you the best advice
if you call me you say you got a warrant
a misdemeanor one and you're sick of
living there anyway
I'll give you the whole [__] plan A
to Z for free I know exactly where you
go how they won't find you how to get a
nice Labor's job and stay under the
[__] radar till the heat blows over
anyway and now for a word for my
sponsors over there at better help who I
[__] love the joint is sponsored by
better help online therapy listen
everything takes work that you're gonna
do nothing is just you show up and it's
done a lot of us will drop anything to
go [__] help somebody I got a brother
George forget about it you know before
he goes to work no I had to go help this
guy change a flat I had to [__] you go
to what but there's people who live
their life like that but instead of
taking care of themselves like they take
care of the people they don't we need to
invest in ourselves all right I invest
in myself I go and exercise therapy
acupuncture I get my blood test [__]
this morning I gotta go to a knee doctor
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to take care of the most
important relationship you got which is
the one you have with yourself listen
I didn't know what the [__] was going on
I called a few therapists everybody
wouldn't take me I went on some website
because I didn't know what was going on
I wanted to talk to a third party my
wife don't know everything you know what
I'm saying I contacted a friend of mine
she told me to go to better help and
contact Dana and I'll tell you what
after like six seven eight weeks of
talking to Dana
I feel tipped I'm gonna go you guys have
seen the change I feel [__] great I
did a couple worksheets you touch base
with them you know you could see the
appointments once a week or twice a
month or whatever the hell you want to
do whether it's hitting the gym taking
time for a haircut or even trying
therapy your greatest asset is to invest
time and effort into yourself you
understand me so better help online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anybody on cam
if you don't want it it's much more
affordable than in person therapy and
you could be matched with a therapist
you ready for this in less than 48 hours
less than two days give it a try and see
why over two million people have used
better help online therapy the joint is
sponsored by better help and listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
Joey that's betterhelp.com
slash Joey let me tell you something
give it a shot trust me you're going to
be happy you did everybody needs a third
opinion a second opinion to run things
by and this is the way to go better help
it's cheap it's affordable and Uncle Joy
gets you a little ten percent off for
your first month just by using Code Diaz
d-i-a-z so I didn't jump off the [__]
Bridge
and I continued my little [__]
onslaught of uh being a full-time
[__] junkie
and December 12th
1983-84
I went to the house and they sat me down
and said listen well you've been here
for a month
you haven't showed
you showed zero of wanting to do
anything with your life
I'm like you're right
for right now I just want to get high
I want to go out at night
that's all I want can you imagine I
didn't want to work
I don't want to do nothing I just wanted
to sell a little bit of Coke
and keep getting high that's it I didn't
care that I was homeless you know
when you choose addiction over a home
there's a problem
again when you choose addiction over a
[__] home
an apartment a space
there's a [__] problem and I had a
[__] problem
but I didn't know how long I was gonna
ride this [__] ship to I'm like [__]
it
I have no [__] prospects I got
nothing in front of me nothing's going
on nobody's gonna hire me my skin looked
bad I mean I was 20 21 22 years old I
was in great shape but
I wasn't doing nothing with it my mind
was gone and
you know I I
looking back at it now that was the time
period
where that little anger started building
of the things I didn't have I started
worrying about that [__] The Hanger
started building and I'm gonna be honest
with you looking back on it now it's so
weird I went to Jujitsu Friday
I went yesterday I went Saturday too and
uh
the guy was saying the attack begins way
before
you think the attack begins you think
the attack begins when you're in side
control and you're going for an American
right that but he was saying no the
attack starts when you start rolling
your body and they don't know it that
the attack is starting they think you're
going into a choke or something
I I always feel that that was the
beginning that was when I I lit the
that's when I turned the switch on
and the final result was me kidnap and
Bella but that's we're way ahead of
ourselves right now but that's how deep
and dark I had gotten I had in my life
had never ever been that dark when I
think about that time period in my life
I don't feel good you ever think of
something like right away you don't feel
good I don't feel good because I wasn't
healthy I wasn't healthy physically but
most importantly I wasn't there [__]
mentally I had you know
by December of 84 guys I had burned
every bridge
in my arson
every bridge I maybe had
Mike Ronnie
maybe three or four people that loved me
and took me but everybody else is a
little on the jaded side with me if you
know what I mean you know I had pissed a
couple people off and they were
childhood friends a lot of childhood
friends that
weren't mad at me they would just uh
I disappointed them
you know and I still remember and I I
made amends with a lot of those guys
and I apologize to them for
you know bringing [__] into their lives
because that's all I was at that time
I was just bringing [__] into your life
if I bumped into you Mike guaranteeing a
week
there was going to be something going on
which either you were missing money
you gave me money for Coke and you never
got it your car was missing you know
that was what I did in people's lives
and I'm really sorry for that part of my
life but yeah Hey listen we all know
somebody like the guy I'm describing to
you when you look at me and you listen
to my stories you're like Joey that
couldn't have been you no
that was me that's why this road tastes
so much better to me like this was all
because
I didn't I wasn't just the guy that got
myself out of the [__] prison system
became a comedian I pulled myself out of
so many different [__] holes to
become that I had to pull myself out of
20 hoes just to become a human being
just to be a human being
like I was way off [__] track as a
developmental I was gone that was all
gone thank God that the pieces got put
together for me and eventually I made it
happen but guys this this was not good
for a long
[__] time you know I went to lunch
with Lisa a couple weeks ago right down
the corner here on the nine
went to get some sushi and we would talk
I brought it up to Iowa do you remember
me and 84 like I'll never forget that I
went to a party a Christmas party and I
saw her at the party I was [__]
homeless I was showering and stuff and I
had cocaine I had money but I was pretty
much homeless
and I saw her at this party
you know I loved them I had a crush on
us she was the only [__] girl I
looked at her as a meal ticket I looked
at hers
a way to get me out of the mess I was
and maybe getting the point I didn't
[__] know I didn't know I had this
you know like when you have this mind
[__] going on that you're gonna sail off
into the sunset
you know this chick was motivated she
was working she was going to school
I saw at a party and I'm like you know
can I talk to you and she's like no I
was like that's not a good place I'm
with my new boyfriend I was [__]
heartbroken that was a horrible
Christmas that was like Christmas Eve
and I remember I said well listen I need
to talk to you please I kept asking I
asked and asking
she's like okay let's go into the
bathroom and went to the bathroom we
were there for like four minutes and she
just smacked me in the face and walked
out like she was like I can't do this
anymore
know who the [__] you are
you know at that time my my nose is
always
stuffed I I always had a bloody nose
you know I heard a story about a
comedian years ago I got to the club
and they were telling me at the comedian
that was dead a week before was doing
coke and his his nose
yeah he did a line during the show or
something like that I don't know
and they said that the blood was falling
from his nose onto the stage and it was
just like you know like [__] dog when
I heard that story I'm like I'll never
forget when the club manager told me
that this had to be years ago six years
ago seven years ago
but I was like oh I hope he's not
talking about me I mean that never
happened to me as a comic
but in 84 my nose was so bad but I would
just start bleeding anyway
and I would put a tissue in my nose and
continue to talk to you like nothing
happened and then the other nose would
start bleeding oh my God guys you have
no idea
there were times I wake up in the
morning I couldn't breathe
not because of sleep apnea because
between the cocaine the cut
and the [__] blood it would coagulate
in my nose and there was just one little
thing in there and I would wake up
because my [__] nose was clogged from
Powder
and blood
I've never said these things anywhere
publicly before because of the shame I
had and this all came to me the other
[__] night when I was just looking at
that rocket ship it was like a 15 minute
you know like when they have a
like The Longest Yard has one that shows
Bill Burt Reynolds hitting me that it
shows the guys breaking into a locker
then it shows her Burt Reynolds hit me
again I don't know what that called
montages guys it was like on the drive
home like I was like I gotta get the
[__] out of here my mind is speeding and
I had a little Vapor pack I brought buds
with me for my friends and some ABX
edibles but I didn't have a joint with
me anything rolled I had a lighter in
the car
but I said [__] it you know I'll figure
something I just did not it just was not
working for me I can't believe
how much of a like for me to tell you
guys that I lived in a rocket ship and
all this [__] God damn
that was big I wouldn't even tell my I
wouldn't tell anybody that [__]
I didn't tell my
wife then girlfriend
maybe like
eight years into the relationship that I
was homeless in 84 and she was like what
why and you know I was ashamed and I
told I told them on the church what's
happening now
people were like what the [__] are you
talking about man
you sleep outside
that builds a little bit of [__]
character like you remember those nights
I tell you there's nights I go to bed
now like maybe once a month twice a
month
when I lay down and I put the sleep
apnea mask on and [__] I put the
blankets on my head I'm like [__] could
you imagine if I was living like by a
train station like underneath like I had
a friend that lived
he wasn't a friend guys he was a guy
bought drugs from in New York City he
lived by when I used to work at the
Sheridan 52nd Street he was a homeless
guy and one day he wanted to show me we
had become like friends the guy never
failed me he was one of those Street
connects that he'll take you over there
get a bag for 20 but give me five bucks
just to hook me up for me taking care of
he was one of those guys
so one day he showed me where the [__]
he lived he lived by Washington Square
Park you went down to the subway
downstairs and he keep walking and it
was like when it turns black and there's
no more war he would walk back there dog
we walked like 10 feet and you could
hear mice rats that's exactly what you
would think would it would sound like
and all of a sudden he goes into a
hallway and he [__] swept the floor
put bricks on there and he pulled it up
I mean it took him like a month this
poor bastard but he lived underneath the
train station somewhere in New York City
and he goes that down Mall there was
like [__] caves where there were 30
homeless people they killed pigs and
dogs and they had to eat them they don't
come out of the [__] puddles oh yeah
that's some creepy [__] [__] in the
New York City
train this people at the dog he said
that there's times when it gets cold he
wouldn't live leave that thing for two
or three days
he had a little bottle to piss he had a
little toilet a makeshift like a spackle
bucket he had one of those I
thought I gotta hand it to people like
that they're crafty
he had pictures up of his family he had
like a like a a those lights that you
take camping
that you fill up with uh gas or whatever
he had it all he took showers at some
church
when he wanted to take a shower or
something like that and listen
being homeless ain't that bad it sucked
for me I didn't have my [__] together I
didn't have no pictures of my relatives
or [__] a blanket or none of that
[__] you it's a jacket Thug it's a
[__] jacket
that's a blanket and a pillow I would
buy like a [__] pint of vodka
and go to the bar and put vodka in the
orange juice like the puke that I am you
know
and I would save like three fingers of
it so when I got back to the
the [__] uh whatever that's what I
would drink before I go to sleep
when you're outside no I would sip on it
all night I'd never drank vodka again
since that
this reminds me it's a [__] ugly
memory of the
they weren't screwdrivers I didn't have
money for orange juice
it was an unscrewed driver jacked
what do you think I was homeless but I
had I had money for orange juice I was
in the [__] my little rocket ship
making cocktails like Tom Cruise and
[__] get the [__] out of here I was
living it rough man
I don't even know what the [__] happened
that year like I just
I went up to uh my base of operations
then was the Midtown Lounge it was
sharples's joint
and you know you go up there you could
put lunch on the arm you could put we
ran a tab for alcohol so you know I
would go up there eat have a couple
[__] sodas put it on my tab sell some
coke
pay the tab off it's a [__] horrible
life but I gotta tell you something it
was working
I was just doing this every day
and I had no idea what my next move was
at this time I owed my godfather money
he was looking for me
I owed some Cubans money in West New
York oh my God I was a [__] mess
but all I did every day then was [__]
wake up at the
[__] rocket ship I would walk either
to either Kurt De Lorenzo's or Mike
Ronnies
I would try to get something to eat at
Kurtz and then go to Mike bunnies his
mother and his father went home so I
could take a shower
the daytime his mother was a cop so
sometimes she stopped at the house
I never bumped into I think one time I
was leaving and she was coming in she
said what are you doing here
I can't believe something from Mike
nobody knew my secret life I would just
walk down walk down the park down the
Grand Avenue I would go to Kurtz
maybe steal one of coach wrestling
shirts or something like that just a
different t-shirt to put on just so I
wouldn't I'd have like a change of
clothes and Mike's
I had walked the mic runnies take a
shower there
and then I'd go to hashways I put like a
semi breakfast on the tab Mrs Ash Gray
love me
and then I'd walk to the Midtown lounge
and wait for the day to pop open who
needs to pound the weed who needs a gram
of coke who needs an eight ball who
needs 10 hits of masculine that was my
job
and usually by one o'clock somebody will
walk in looking for something
and me and my [__] buddies would help
them out and eight ball whatever and
then we'd start from that we got a half
gram off the top that's 50 bucks what
are we going to do let's sell the half
Grand let's borrow 100 from with it you
know it was just getting eight balls and
selling them and that I was just making
enough to break even and if there were
days that I made enough to break even I
would get a hotel room
for a night just uh and I would go there
like at 12 take a tremendous shower
sleep I'd get a late check out you know
I'd stay off the street as little much
as I could every minute that I could
and one day
I went down to the Midtown Lounge
it was like
the 26th of December
I had nothing going on I don't even know
what I was waiting for guys I was just
waiting for something to happen I didn't
know what
I just knew something was going to
happen
I [__] uh
was at the Midtown Lounge one day and I
would just went outside to get some mail
you know
and I remember in those times that's the
only places I went in the daytime with
bars I was either at the Midtown lines
90 percent of the time or if I did
something bad for a few days I would go
to Corky's and hide for three or four
days and then I'd go back to the Midtown
Lounge
and one night I'm in front of them one
afternoon I'm in front of the Midtown
Lounge reminding my own business just
looking at the traffic on Kennedy
[__] Boulevard
and one of my teachers was driving by
and he beeped the horn at me
and I was so happy to see him like I
hadn't seen him in like a year or so
and he came out of his car and he's like
look at you and we [__] hugged and
[__] what's going on Mr TV after the
whole thing he looked at me he's like
bro you don't look good
and I broke down I go Mr T I'm not good
I can't stop snorting
can't stop being a piece of [__]
I need a break I gotta get something I
need something I need I don't know I
need a overhaul I need an apartment I
need money I need a car I need a bicycle
I need clothes I need [__] to rest I
need to get my head together at that
time I needed a lot of [__] things
guys you know
and he's like listen man I've been clean
for a while now I'm involved with uh
AAA and stuff there was no na back then
I don't I don't know what the [__] that
was back then
he goes I know a lot of people in AAA I
could probably get you into a rehab and
get you some money or get you into a
detox
and get you a little money they'll put
you on a program and stuff maybe a
halfway house to get on your feet
and at that point I would say yes to
anything I was like let's do it
and he goes take my number
568-9457
[__] think you're dealing with guys
40 years later
and uh I said listen I'm gonna get my
[__] together
I was planning to somebody was had to go
down
everything I I had been [__] just
spinning my wheels for the last
60 60 days
something had to go down and at that
point
like I said this that was the beginning
of my criminal real criminality when I
had a like somebody needs to [__]
step up I'm gonna need to [__] mug
somebody with guns and I'm not talking
about 3 000 bucks I gotta go in that
[__] heavy I ain't got time to [__]
around with these people
so I [__] uh told him I call him in a
few days he says he'll get me and he
says I'm gonna go to my mother's house
and get on the phone right now
and start getting you a detox or
whatever I can get you
and I said let's go for New Year's Day
1985 he goes okay I'll be around
so at this point I had started [__]
slinging code for this kid but he had
his eye on me this [__] was
slick smart
and I could get nowhere with him I had
been working with him like maybe 60 30
days
and this [__] knew my angles
from all directions
but I knew eventually he was going to
open up you know what I'm saying it's
just like Jiu Jitsu you're going for the
Kimora the guy straightens his arm out
switch it around go for the choke now he
raises his arm and you got his arm right
there to slam it down so I knew I knew I
eventually I would catch this guy off
guard and sure enough the opportunity
came New Year's Eve because I'm going to
be in the city hanging out all night
what I'm going to do is just give you a
couple ounces you don't have to keep
calling me and I'll square up with you
first thing [__] New Year's Day in
the morning
I said fine he [__] uh gave me a
couple bags we sold them New Year's Eve
came he gave me a couple ounces I did
everything perfectly and I had my
[__] day planned the [__] out
I was gonna sell all the [__] Coke
pocket the money
Joelle was supposed to pick me up that
morning and I I totally Avenue the hotel
that wasn't happening
I was gonna [__] leave before he even
[__] knew what the hell was going on
I called Mr T I told him I was getting
everything ready
he said he had spoken to the people at
the rehab and they couldn't get me in
but the people at the detox could get me
in and that was a 30-day detox
so I'm in a hotel for 30 days it's going
to be beautiful like the detox they'll
give me food I could get a phone make
some calls maybe put a couple dollars
together I was [__] psyched New
Year's Eve came my man came through gave
me a couple [__] Oz
I sold and snorted every [__] last
drop of that [__] because you
know how Uncle Joey's a [__] fiend
I slept maybe an hour and I called Mr T
and I said pick me the [__] up at the
tip top Hotel on Donnelly [__] Avenue
that's the name of tick tock or Tip Top
I don't [__] know it's disgusting
this hotel disgusting when you lay on
the bed even if they have sheets on you
could smell sperm I mean they have a
jacuzzi tub I rented it one night for
like the small 60 bucks oh my God
you know you ever see a Jacuzzi like the
foam goes around the sides with the
bubbles and you have to like scrape the
bubbles from the wall that was mixed
with sperm so when you hit the bubbles
it was just got dog I wouldn't even
[__] and those hotels
still there today the same hotels
there's one on 91st and tunley Avenue
and that one I was talking about the tip
top whatever the [__] it is
that's still there disgusting that's
where I got my fungi don't help him
those showers no dirty hotel rooms
that's why I got my [__] [__]
but dog I'd never
ever ever thought I was gonna get myself
out at all
in fact when Mr T came to pick me up
when I got into Mr T's car and slammed
the [__] car as I looked up and put
the seat belt on Joelle was driving into
the hotel
he had just caught like I woke up that
morning called T I said t come get me he
goes we got a snow storm it's gonna be
about an hour and all of a sudden I'm
packed I'm ready to go and the phone
rings it's Joe out
what's up Joel listen I'll be down there
in about an hour I'm like [__]
if Joel shows before T I won't have any
money to leave I put together like maybe
four or five grand a couple [__]
Grand yeah yeah I had it down Jack
wow I just got bad news
my sister passed away in Cuba yesterday
at at 6 00 PM
yeah they had only given her a week
yeah they called me
again
that's not good guys
yeah
I'm sorry brother ah
it happens guys
it's weird too because when before I got
the call from my niece to tell me my
sister was sick
for some reason I just kept thinking
about my mother
like it was just like I couldn't shake
it you know like [__] what the
and then I got the text last week and
I'm gonna tell you what the [__]
saddest thing in the world is
I couldn't get a calling card all week
I went to every [__] gas station I
went to Wawa
I went to the gas station up the corner
I went to a liquor store I couldn't get
a [__] calling card
so uh what are you gonna do guys it's
just another [__] day and her
birthday is
she would have been
a birthday is Sunday the 20th
my birthday is February 19th her
birthday is March 19th
we were born a month a [__] part
this is a Monday morning [__] podcast
[__] we ended with a death
that's the way to really [__] end the
podcast no
but my message today on a Monday morning
was
if I got myself out of the mess I was in
that was a [__] 10 month curse
if I would have
it was deep guys
I needed a lot to shake that off it took
me maybe a year to get on my [__]
feet I mean I got on my feet in like six
months Financial I didn't get high
anymore I didn't get high for about
three years I did pretty [__] good
that uh like I said to you guys that
little homeless that little stunt we
talked about today
it's deep in my [__] soul I never
wanted to go back there you know I don't
mind going to a couple places you never
know
I might clock some guy in the head with
a pipe in two years and go to jail for
[__] life you know you never know but
I know one thing for sure I don't ever
want to be homeless
I don't ever not want to have a dime in
the bank or any security whatsoever I'm
the jacket I had somebody bought it for
me
a friend of mine goes you have winter
jacket I don't know
he goes come on let's go down the
[__] slashing just I'll buy you a
winter jacket I'm embarrassing it is and
then I got into a fight two nights later
I got ripped
so the [__] jacket that whole window
when I was homeless I was walking around
with a winter jacket and the whole
[__] Hood was ripped from we got into
a fist fight and they were holding us
back so
my message is if I got myself out of
that [__] hole and there was no plan
there was no goals back then there was
no notebook that was like well this will
take me six months there was nothing it
was just me against the [__]
world and I think till this day me
getting out of that was my strength I
always knew if I got myself out of that
one I get myself on anything ever
anything anything they threw at me and
I'm till this day like the prison
sentence I got
me getting divorced and uh the situation
with my daughter this situation I told
you about these were the stories that
defined who I was guys
and it's so weird to think that these I
never knew that that Homeless thing had
affected me so much until Thursday night
basically 39 [__] years later I
didn't know that it pissed me off and I
didn't even know I didn't have parents
I didn't have I had good friends but I
had to let them all down I let everybody
down it at that time but who gave a [__]
about that I had let down the most
important person in my world which was
me and I never wanted to be there again
ever if you're in this position right
now in your life
if you're struggling
and you think it's that [__] far away
from you to get healthy I'm here to tell
you you're wrong it's right around the
[__] Corner because if I got myself
healthy from that in 85 84
. guys I never thought I was going to
recover from that you heard me I didn't
know what my next move was
I had nothing coming in there was no way
I could get a job I had three pair of
pants
two T-shirts and a winter jacket or
something and I barely had that
it was just a bad [__] time in my
life and when I look at those situations
these situations taste that much better
and yeah Joey what are you worried about
it happened a long time ago nobody
remembers I remember [__] and
that's the most important person there's
a lot of things I don't remember
I keep those memories really close to me
but this one from Thursday night I'm
going to keep even closer
because I never wanted to end up in that
place again and it wasn't even sleeping
in the rocket ship money that [__] it
was what was going on in my life and
around me I never want that confusion
again I'll stick with the [__] weed
and we'll all be [__] happy forever
laughing gases and stock [__] suckers
the NCAA finals are here and it's a
beautiful [__] day to be alive thank
you for watching The Joint thank you for
listening to my ear beating we got a
tremendous guest on Wednesday and we'll
be ready to rock I love you
[__] stay black have a great
day I'll see you [__] Wednesday
morning Tip Top Magoo I love you Spotify
all right you bad [__] I want
to thank you for listening today for
having my back and always supporting me
whether it's here the patreon Laughing
gases in stock rainbow ruts
white truffle and the cocoa killing
[__] but anyway let's start the
party off with the joint is brought to
you by DraftKings listen this weekend is
the NCAA basketball tournament it starts
Thursday [__] everybody joins
these things what I'm gonna do for you
on DraftKings is turn your team's
Victory into your win new customers sign
up right now download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app but find out any college
team to win if they win you get 200 free
bets and you can play with those free
bets the whole month of March if they
win you win that's what this is called
[__] now with sportsbookers and
you're available in your state yet you
can still join the college hoops action
with DraftKings pools they're tremendous
everybody can play for free the whole
month of March to win a share 250 000
000 prizes
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
now use promo code Joey and get five
dollars on any college hoop team to win
and get two allows and free bets if they
do if they win you win with promo code
Joey this week at DraftKings Sportsbook
restrictions do apply the joint is also
brought to you by better help one of my
favorites listen you gotta take care of
yourself the last two years have been
tough on everybody including your psyche
if you need to speak with somebody do I
have the person to speak to you better
help online therapy listen you need to
invest in yourself a lot more you're out
there trying to help everybody else you
got to take care of yourself better help
online therapy wants to remind you to
take care of the most important
relationship you have the one with
yourself I've been with better help now
for about eight months nine months
they're one of the best things I ever
did you guys know I never went to
therapy before so this has been been
tremendous Dana has helped me in ways I
can't even describe so whether it's
hitting the gym making time for your
haircut
or even trying therapy you're the
greatest asset so invest the time and
effort into yourself better help is
online therapy
that off his video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anybody on cam if you
don't want to it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours
give it a try see why 2 million have
used better up online therapy the joint
is sponsored by better help and
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
showy again that's betterhelp.com Diaz
I'm sorry Diaz d-i-a-z and last but not
least listen everybody wants to sling
dick it's [__] Saint Patty's Day
they're halfway there everybody's
drinking green beer you're gonna have
somebody puke green beer on your dick
it's gonna be great blue shoe is here
for Saint Patty's Day their motto Blow
Me I'm Irish listen blue chew is the
best take it anyway anytime day and
night 30 minutes just slinging dick like
no [__] can
I want your girlfriend will call you
George or the jungle you understand me
and the process is simple
sign up at Bluetooth
.com and talk to one of the licensed
medical providers this is quick guys
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
of it guys it's all online no doctor's
office no Pharmacy no judgment it ships
right to your door in a discreet package
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
way cheaper than a pharmacy so listen
whether you have Ed or not you always
could use some extra confidence slinging
dick and knocking down that third war
try Bluetooth for free you're like Joy
what are you talking about free free
when you use promo code Joey j-o-e-y at
checkout just pay five dollars for
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
Joey to receive your first month Gratis
free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
I want to thank Bluetooth for sponsoring
to join I also want to thank DraftKings
I also want to thank Better Health a
tremendous service and I want to thank
you guys for having my back and for
listening this week thank you we'll be
back Wednesday Tip Top [__]
Magoo stay black
foreign